so what we're doing today  it's a really easy day today you're  doing a backflip over mark  and then next up you see those three  massive stunt guys that were in this  morning yeah you've got to fight then  and then it's that shot of you getting  thrown into the table i'm sorry i think  it's a character thing  [Music]  you're then doing that bit when you  smash that guy in the face with the uh  the glass box oh yeah with a glass  bottle like that  and then we just finished with you  getting hit by a car  that's it hang on if time permits tom to  do a jump over a 50-foot drop catching  himself on a chandelier  but i don't think we'll get to it i  don't think i'm against that i don't  think i can do that i don't think you  can do that either  [Music]  [Music]  you